I was listening to a podcast and he mentioned that high D-H-E-A was a risk factor for breast
kids.
Why would that be?
Because D-H-E-A is a formal and D-H-E-A is a precursor to testosterone and progesterum.
So that's why it is a risk factor for breast cancer when it's elevated.
That's why I don't recommend people take D-H-E-A.
So it's very common.
That's a supplement.
You could get that anywhere and it's very common to take D-H-E-A and have doctors who
recommend D-H-E-A, especially when people have adrenal fatigue.
So all you have adrenal fatigue just take D-H-E-A, and that will really help.
Well, it really will.
But it's a precursor to progesterone and testosterone, which then is a precursor to 4idroxyesterone,
which can increase your risk.
The breast cancer.
I had a Dutch test almost two years ago and they noted in my report that my D-H-E-A was
within range but higher than expected for my age.
Is there anything I should cross reference in my genetics results on that issue or any
other results in the Dutch test that could give me more clues about what caused or fuels
my cancer?
I think in the genetics, we'll show the correlation with D-H-E-A, doing another Dutch test could
be beneficial.
So it depends, you did the Dutch test two years ago, you should probably do it again.
You can order it at our store.
So we said you're the kid, you're doing it at home, you said it at and we talk about the
results.
Doing another Dutch test would be the thing to do.
And we do the Dutch, I think it's called the Dutch complete, which also gives you a whole
adrenal profile and measures your D-H-E-A to see.